l'annoncé des fiançailles du prince
william et de kate middleton 16 novembre
2010 a réjoui le monde en tienne en
dévoilant la belle histoire que le
public attendait c'était très romantique
où il est un grand romantique c'est vrai
dans un climat de crise financière des
félicitations sont arrivés du monde
entier pour saluer l'événement qui
marque également le nouveau rôle de kate
en tant que princesse célébrités
peur la première fois dans l'histoire de
la monarchie une roturière va épouser un
membre de la famille royale et la
descendance royale en sera changée à
jamais beaucoup de gens est une réaction
négative en entendant le terme aux
tueries
c'est vraiment un mot atroce quand on y
pense c'est un véritable conte de fées
dans tous les sens du terme
pour la première fois depuis des siècles
un futur roi va épouser une femme qui
n'est pas de sang royal née d'une
famille royale étrangères ni de
l'aristocratie britannique
à la veille de l'un des événements
royaux les plus passionnants du
millénaire des proches bien informée
nous révèle ce qui rend le jeune couple
si spécial personne n'a pu déterré un
seul scandale sur cette jeune femme et
dieu sait qu'ils ont essayé quelques
éclipses déjà toutes les stars
incontournables comme jennifer aniston
gwyneth paltrow c'est elle que le public
le connaît si son looping que les jambes
et les miss c'est vraiment incroyable
il a tout de spencer dans son apparence
et son caractère il a du charme une
propension à rire cette sensibilité
typique des spencer résume bien le
personnage je pense que le jour où il y
au fer la bague
c'était un moyen pour lui de prendre les
rênes de cette histoire de la maîtriser
c'est à mon avis ce qu'il voulait il
nous a tous conviés à inclure sa mère
dans ce mariage et c'est ce que tout le
monde fera
v quest enez tout le monde se demande
qui sera l'heureux élu qui créera la
robe de mariée de la décennie tous les
créateurs prestigieux pour se battre
pour habiller kate middleton des slicks
voici l'histoire extraordinaire et
secrète de l'idylle de kate et william
presque dix ans après que tout a
commencé elle est tour à tour drôle et
triste mais toujours passionnant
[Musique]
il y en a il est l'héritier du trône
britannique
une fils de la plus grande célébrité du
monde noir elle et sa fiancée
plus une femme belle élégante et
cultiver une nouvelle étoile brillant au
firmament du showbiz même lorsque
william et kate ont annoncé leurs
fiançailles
il semblait très à l'aise dans leur rôle
de futur mari et femme c'est simple cela
fait un moment que nous sommes ensemble
et oui je pense être quelqu'un de plutôt
drôle elle aime ça et tout se passe bien
entre nous leurs familles semblent se
réjouir tout autant qu à la perspective
du mariage royal le plus illustre de ces
trente dernières années
j'aimerais dire que carole et moi sommes
vraiment ravis d'apprendre cette
nouvelle
quelle est votre réaction à l'annoncé du
mariage mais je suis bien sûr ravi merci
beaucoup
ça fait longtemps que je m'entraîne pas
de boire belle histoire d'amour royal
n'a pas toujours été aussi ludique
lorsque kate se plaint du harcèlement
médiatique dont elle est victime
le jeune prince menace la presse d'une
action en justice il n'est plus temps de
se sépare en avril 2007
mais quelques mois plus tard au grand
soulagement de leurs familles et amis
les amoureux se réconcilient cet
incident malheureux
kate est devenue un symbole d'élégance à
part entière elle incarne la grâce et le
style et sa garde-robe inspire
aujourd'hui certains magazines
prestigieux tels que tacleur à chaque
époque
abdé comment cette cendrillon des temps
modernes at-elle conquis son prince
charmant un homme apprécié dans le monde
entier il faut avouer qu'il est
probablement l'un des meilleurs partie
du pays et voir du monde
mais kate a su tirer son épingle du jeu
elle a joué la carte de l'amitié pour
permettre à williams d'apprendre à la
connaître
sans trop faire pression sur lui et ça a
fini par payer
je suis convaincu que l'une des choses
qui a attiré william berkley et c'est
qu'elle a eu la vie qu'il aurait rêvé
d'avoir
[Musique]
kate moss bonne catherine elizabeth
middleton surnommée kate est né le 9
janvier 1982 à reading dans le comté de
berks son enfance aux côtés de son frère
james et de sa soeur pippa semble avoir
été heureuse à bien des égards
je pense qu'elle a eu une enfance
remplit de bonheur
l'esprit de famille et je crois que
c'est ce qui a attiré où il ya le fait
qu'elle vienne d'une familiaux il faut
se souvenir que keita deux parents la
famille de sa mère vient d'un milieu
modeste il était mineur et appartenait à
la classe ouvrière mais le père de kate
michael middleton vient d'un milieu
privilégié qui comptait plusieurs
millionnaires
donc même si kate vient plutôt de la
classe moyenne voire même populaire sa
famille est riche et l'argent s'est
transmis de générations en générations
les middleton ont pu offrir à chacun de
leurs trois enfants une école à 27
milles livres il avait hérité de
beaucoup d'argent à la naissance de kate
fade
si l'on remonte plus loin dans le temps
son arrière grand père maternel
appartenait à la classe ouvrière minière
il y avait peu de semble dans la lignée
famille
la ténacité et la détermination étaient
leurs traits dominants pense que cela a
aidé kate dans son jeu de patience avec
le prince d'ailleurs sa soeur pippa
était surnommé les soeurs lissine à
l'école décoratives et capable de
s'élever rapidement ces deux jeunes
femmes sortaient toujours avec les
garçons les plus huppés les plus riches
les plus brillants et bien sûr kate a
réussi à attirer le meilleur parti de
tout rôle la mère de kate était une
jeune femme ambitieuse elle a grandi à
saltor ce n'était pas un très bon
quartier c'était un peu comme de vivre
près des pistes d'atterrissage de
l'aéroport john f kennedy à new york
en regardant par la fenêtre elle voyait
les gros avion en train d'atterrir
elle se disait qu'elle voulait devenir
hôtesse de l'air c'est ce qu'elle est
devenue
elle a ensuite rencontré un pilote et
elle a finit par l'épouser
cette famille est marqué par l'ambition
bon sens du terme il n'était pas
possible ne l'ont jamais été salaire de
pilotes mais ils ont décidé de fonder
leur propre entreprise parti pis ils ont
trouvé une niche commerciale pour les
ventes par correspondance et par
internet
il proposait tout le nécessaire pour
l'organisation de fêtes d'enfance riches
le fait que sa famille dirige une
entreprise appelée marty qui lui attire
la sympathie du public parce que ça lui
donne l'air de quelqu'un simple je pense
que ses amis se moquer beaucoup d'elle
il aller en boîte ensemble certains de
ses copains lui disait en plaisantant
désarmement des portes en référence au
fait que sa mère avait été hôtesse de
l'air qui s'épanouit dans un
environnement familial heureux l'enfance
du prince william est un peu moins
facile
dès sa naissance le 21 juin 1982 à
l'hôpital sainte marie ce de londres
fait la une dans le monde entier attend
de voir votre fils d'autres altesse un
hôtel lighting et le peuple anglais
accueillent à bras ouverts le futur
héritier de la couronne panama mère la
princesse diana est déjà devenu une
icône mondiale des millions de gens la
vénère en raison de son caractère
bienveillant et de son petit sourire
timide oui le frère du prince william
harry mais le 15 septembre 1984 à
l'hôpital sainte marie ce de paddington
le pitch tu as eu le trône britannique a
désormais un héritier est une pièce de
rechange le même bas je me souviens
avoir dit à la princesse diana en voyant
son fils devenir de plus en plus grands
grâce à vous la famille royale à gagner
quelques centimètres et elle a répondu
oui
good luck elle a aussi gagné en beauté
elle faisait référence à l'introduction
de sa famille les spencer dans un
patrimoine génétique royal très
restreint
ce qui a donné deux fils trésor
pas de maison au milieu des années 80 la
popularité éclatante de diana a
complètement éclipsé celle du père de
william le prince charles au moment où
williams arrive à eton l'école la plus
prestigieuse du pays
des nuages sont menaces ce qui était
auparavant un véritable conte de fées
le prince et la princesse de galles se
séparent selon buckingham palace
la décision était prise à l'amiable et
le couple n'a pas l'intention de
divorcer buckingham a déclaré qu'aucun
tir n'était impliqué dans cette décision
dust off ce qui avait débuté comme un
conte de fées était devenu un cauchemar
royal mais le pire reste à venir selon
un communiqué en provenance de paris
princesse diana et son partenaire de
dial fayed trouvé la mort dans un
accident de voiture
il avait apparemment été pris en chasse
par des paparazzis à motors
nous avons certaines des dernières
images de la scène voici la voiture dans
laquelle se trouvait et diana et dodi al
fayed la collision semble avoir été
terrible destin très bien là des airbags
à l'avant du véhicule
selon les rapports diana a été tué
al fayed a également trouvé la mort tout
comme leur chauffeur
[Musique]
à oisy une la tragédie a suscité une
compassion universelle pour les jeunes
frères ont le chagrin a été exposée
publiquement
oui était âgée de 15 ans et harry n'en
avait que 12
en donnant presque dans le monde entier
a versé des larmes
nulle part autant qu'au royaume uni
je suis convaincu que l'une des choses
qui a attiré williams vers qui tu sais
qu'elle a eu la vie qu'il aurait rêvé
d'avoir la sécurité grandir dans la
classe moyenne
fréquenter une bonne école mais sans
avoir à subir toute la pression associée
au statut de prince de membres de la
famille royale l'enfance de williams a
été atroce tout le monde le sait
[Musique]
mais moi à la même époque kate middleton
mène une vie plutôt insouciante
elle est inscrite dans l'une des écoles
les plus chers et prestigieuse
d'angleterre le marlboro collège dans le
wiltshire crise il ya l'enfance de kate
n'a pas été toute rose avant son entrée
au marlboro collège elle était en école
préparatoire où elle a subi des brimades
elle était très malheureux elle a
beaucoup maigri si elle était désespérée
et ses parents ont été assez
intelligents pour comprendre ce qu'elle
n'était pas faite pour cette école se
sont donc enseigner et ont découvert
malbos la scolarité y était très cher
mais ils ont décidé que c'était la
meilleure chose la kate middleton que
nous connaissons aujourd'hui est très
différente de l'écolière timide et
asthmatique qui avait très peu d'amis ce
n'était pas le genre de fille avec
laquelle ses camarades voulaient être
vus a toujours été perçu comme une
collégienne plein d'entrain très
studieuse qui avait de bons résultats
elle était très appréciée elle était
sportive elle pratiquer de nombreux
sports
de manière générale personne n'a pu lui
reprocher quoi que ce soit ce qui est
remarquable sujet de kate middleton
c'est qu'il n'y a aucun scandale dans
son passé que ce soit un incident où
elle aurait été malpoli ou aurait
maltraité quelqu'un il n'y a rien du
tout au départ elle n'était pas
tellement populaires lorsque les filles
arrivaient à la cantine
les gars ont levé des serviettes en
papier sur lesquelles il avait inscrit
une note pour dire s'il trouvait la
fille attirante
ou pas au tout début elle était plutôt
maigre d'onéreuses tout timide les
garçons lui donner comme note 1 1 - 0 -
2 noms soient très plaisant pour une
jeune fille mais elle ne s'est pas
plainte
elle n'a pas pleuré elle n'a pas demandé
à changer d'école elle a pris sur elle
et ses efforts ont payé
elle s'est un peu arrondie elle a pris
des couleurs
elle est devenue plus sûre d'elle est
plus attirant c'était quelqu'un de
populaire sans pour autant se met
probablement trop chez sense in fine à
saint gobain vous ne trouverez personne
parmi ses anciens camarades de classe
qui et quoi que ce soit de mal à dire à
son sujet elle était sportive dynamique
attentive aux autres amicales bon élève
de quoi la détester non
les garçons sont extrêmement protégé
après le décès de leur mère on demande
aux médias de laisser william est à 31
ans dans leur scolarité à la mort de la
princesse diana
un accord a été conclu avec la presse
britannique qui ne devait pas approcher
william et harry
en contrepartie nous recevions de temps
à autre des informations sur ce qui se
passait dans leur vie marché au rythme
désormais à l'abri des médias souvent
tenu pour responsable de la mort
tragique de lady di et garçons emprunte
le chemin difficile menant de
l'adolescence à l'âge adulte sans la mer
qu'ils vont aimer de tout leur coeur
est quand même et puis le temps fait son
oeuvre et la vie des jeunes princes se
reconstruit williams mûri et devient un
jeune homme timide mais confirme qui de
l'aveu général a hérité de la
gentillesse de sa mère et du sens du
devoir de son père le prince william est
quelqu'un de chanceux surtout parce
qu'il a un caractère très semblable à
celui de sa mère il a tout d'un spencer
dans son apparence et son caractère il a
du charme une propension arrive les gens
ne le savent pas parce que diana était
souvent soucieuse mais elle avait
beaucoup d'humour
elle adorait rire jusqu'à en avoir mal
au ventre
elle se plier en deux et rillettes aux
larmes et will i am et gomez il a bon
coeur
il est plein de bonne volonté il
souhaite toujours le meilleur et il a
réussi à faire son chemin malgré toutes
les difficultés
je pense qu'au cours des années qu'il a
passées aux côtés de sa mère lorsqu'elle
est levée elle a aidé à comprendre le
monde et a réalisé à quel point il était
privilégiée
cette sensibilité typique des spencer
résume bien la personne
les choses sont bien différentes avec le
prince harry
sari et le prince harry est quelqu'un
d'adorable la presse britannique est
dingue de lui c'est un peu l'enfant
terrible membres de la famille royale ne
s'est jamais comporté comme lui ne peut
compter sur lui pour faire des gaffes
il arrive à une fête déguisée en asie
complètement inconscient il va dans un
club de l'avs dancing on le voit
toujours sortir de boîte de nuit
complètement débraillé vous pouvez être
sûr que c'est le dernier à partir le
dernier à prendre un verre et je pense
que ça a quelque chose d'irrésistible
et tu fais en 2000 william décide de
prendre une année sabbatique avant
d'entrer à l'université et par enseigner
au chili je voulais faire quelque chose
de constructif pendant mon année
sabbatique
j'aurais bien sûr pu faire autre chose
mais je me suis dit que c'était une
façon d'aider les autres et de
rencontrer beaucoup de gens différents
venant de pays différents tout en aidant
ceux qui vivent dans des régions
reculées au chili il est peut-être ici
de la noblesse mais en patagonie
depuis nos tâches mais trop humble pour
le futur roi au cours de son expédition
she will have chaque semaine le sol des
toilettes images montrent également le
prince william en train de préparer du
port hic pour le petit déjeuner même
s'il reconnaît lui même que ce ne fut
pas une réussite
le prince a plu aux enfants dans le
village où il séjourne depuis deux mois
il soutient libye avoir choisi cette
région reculée parce qu'il n'était
jamais allé en amérique du sud
et ajoute que les chiliens sont très
accueillants tout n'est cependant pas là
pour prendre des vacances
nous voyons le jeune prince juillet les
bûcherons et les choses ne se passent
pas tout à fait comme prévu
will i am relativise cet échec
quelqu'un veut tenter le coup je sais
pas je suis pas très content là le
prince a également de faire la lessive
avec des résultats mitigés sont toujours
mauvais dit il les traités de la même
façon que ses camarades pendant cette
expédition
ce qui implique dormir à 15 dans une
vieille salle de classe est de couper du
bois pour le chauffage et la cuisine
je m'appelle will et je suis un bon bah
tu es maintenant vous essayez de faire
le bruit du bon bat en donnant des cours
à l'école du village lui montre gelé
naturellement doué avec les enfants
et en plus du physique de sa mère il a
indéniablement hérité de son d'aisance
comment est ce que je me rappelais de sa
williams est revenue de son année
sabbatique plus sûr de lui et plus
détendu que jamais exmar est le rite de
passage suivant l université et laquelle
va-t-il choisir la petite ville
universitaire de saint-andrews qui n'a
jamais connu un tel événement le prince
williams et take l'année comme un héros
lors de son arrivée avec son père avant
même d'avoir assisté à son premier cours
d'histoire de l'art
le prince étudiants et déjà une
célébrité la beauté toutes ces effusions
semble le mettre quelques peu mal à
l'aise mais il ne déçoit pas des
admirateurs dont certains patientent
depuis des heures pour l'apercevoir
merci beaucoup enchantée merci
merci beaucoup
will i am a choisi une tenue
décontractée qui témoigne de son envie
de commencer sa vie d'étudiant et de se
tenir à l'écart de la une des médias
saint-andrews accueille quelques 6000
étudiants dans les deux tiers viennent
d'écoles publiques
williams avez vous hâte de commencer
votre premier trimestre oui vraiment
willie mays hank williams et kate se
rencontrent pendant leur première année
d'études d'histoire de l'art leur
relation est tout d'abord platonique
leur vie universitaire oise était tout
ce qu'il ya de plus normal will i am ne
vivait pas dans un magnifique palais
dans une banlieue chic
il a loué une maison avec des amis ils
formaient un petit cercle d'amis donc et
faisait partie
allez au supermarché dîné ensemble comme
n'importe quel autre étudiant kate et
william se sont rencontrés ils ont
sympathisé tout de suite il a trouvé
plutôt séduisant mais au départ il était
simplement s'il aimait tous les deux
l'histoire de l'art il suivait le même
cursus ils passent leurs soirées à
discuter en buvant du vin tout ça
restait très modérée
william décide de quitter saint-andrews
son père intervient en lui rappelant une
fois de plus son rang et son devoir
williams a rapidement regretter sa
décision d'aller en écosse pour étudier
à saint-andré et il a été à deux doigts
d'abandonner la première année
il a même abordé le sujet avec ses
professeurs en leur disant qu'il ne
voulait pas continuer ses études
à cette époque les médias qui ne leur
donnait pas l'espace de liberté dont ils
avaient besoin
mais avec le recul je pense qu'il est
clair que son intérêt soudain pour kate
middleton a ravivé son désir de finir
ses études à saint-andrews du bois mais
à l'occasion d'un événement bien
particulier
cette relation platonique générant une
tournure beaucoup plus intéressante
l'anecdote fait désormais partie de la
légende
c'est un moment décisif dans l'histoire
de l'angleterre
quand kate middleton alors jeune
étudiante participe un défilé de mode
pour une oeuvre de charité
elle défile sur le podium et le prince
william la regarde les yeux écarquillés
ce qu'elle porte ce qu'on voit sur les
images ne laisse pas beaucoup de place à
l'imagination
je ne sais pas quoi penser williams ce
jour là assis au premier rang du défilé
mais je ne vois pas comment il aurait pu
ne pas la remarquer elle ne portait
quasiment rien d'autre qu'un
soutien-gorge et une culotte mes cheveux
flottants sur les épaules tout bouclé
avec des fleurs elle était magnifique
jeune fraîche et naturelle elle a
vraiment attiré l'attention de williams
ce jour là en dépit de tout ce qui a été
dit sur la personnalité un peu fades ou
terre à terre de kate elle sait se faire
remarquer quand elle le veut et elle a
parfaitement réussi à attirer
l'attention de l'homme dont elle
souhaitait se faire remarquer ce jour là
il ne vous est pas venu à l'esprit
qu'une photo de la future reine
d'angleterre dans cette tenue pouvait
être légèrement inconvenante ou bien sûr
que si
mais à cette époque je suis sûr qu'elle
avait une bonne raison de laporta on ne
sait pas si quelqu'un l'a choisi pour
elle ou si elle a décidé de la porter
mais je préfère penser que c'était son
choix parce qu'elle voulait faire une
entrée remarquée
ça appartient à l'histoire maintenant
mais je ne crois pas qu'elle apporterait
aujourd'hui et vous pouvez acheter cette
robe pour environ dix mille lits la
légende veut que ce soit cette robe qui
est finalement confié williams elle est
convaincue que cette jeune femme
méritait davantage d'attention
lorsque william et kate était à
l'université
il avait beau être prince et lui faisait
la cour en lui préparant des spaghettis
j'apportais des vieux pull il était on
ne peut plus normal et je crois que pour
bien comprendre ce mariage pour bien
comprendre ce conte de fées il faut se
souvenir que c'est la suite d'une
période de normalité
quand je voulait impressionner kate
j'essayais de cuisiner des repas
incroyablement raffiné et à chaque fois
je brûlais quelque chose quelque chose
débordé ou prenait feu elle restait
toujours près de moi pour m'aider ou
prendre les choses en main heureusement
qu'elle était là williams est tombé
amoureux de la famille de kate tout
comme il est tombé amoureux d'elle la
famille middleton est très uni avec
trois enfants heureux et équilibrée et
un couple parental très fort williams
venait souvent au déjeuner dominical
avec un menu typiquement britannique
toute la famille s'asseyaient autour du
feu après déjeuner il pose est peut-être
la tête sur l'épaule de madame middleton
où il y avait été traité comme un membre
de la famille à part entière
je crois qu'il est tombé amoureux de
l'idée d'appartenir pour la première
fois à une famille typiquement anglaise
histoire d'amour a pu se construire
grâce à un accord passé entre le cabinet
royal du prince charles et la press
complaints commission
il se promenait dans le parc sans avoir
à craindre les photographes
les photos ont été prises mais les
journaux s'était engagé à ne pas les
publier conformément à l'accord passé
après la mort de diana elle n'était pas
destinée à un marché
il ne faut pas sous-estimer l'impact que
cela a eu sur leur relation williams a
rencontré kate à l'université alors
qu'il n'était pas harcelé par les médias
mais que sa vie n'était pas publique
fait une crevaison
les équipes de tournage sont interdites
à l'université et pourtant une
révélation mais la famille royale dans
l'embarras il provient d'une source
inattendue
il ya eu une époque terrible où les
médias ne pouvaient pas approcher au
bois ou ne pouvais plus mettre les pieds
à s'attendre aux mêmes si un membre de
notre famille étudier là bas c'était à
ce point là et tout on a appris qu'une
équipe de tournage se trouvait là bas à
suivre williams
et devinez qui était derrière tout ça le
prince édouard après une discussion
animée avec le prince charles
ce projet de film a rapidement été
interrompue
un journaliste travaillant pour ardennes
production est repéré par le jeune
prince en personne alors qu'il tente de
le filmer à la sortie d'un cours selon
le recteur de l'université une bagarre
éclate
lorsqu'il refuse de partir le comte de
wessex possède la société qui commence
par démentir cette infusion en disant
qu'ils ont reçu la permission de filmer
les présente ensuite ses excuses
la société ardennes dès qu'elle ne
voulait pas violer les accords entourant
la vie privée du prince et ajoute
qu'elle présente ses plus sincères
excuses si les activités de l'équipe de
production ont compromis ces accords
d'incidents est une véritable source
d'embarras pour la famille royale et
soulève une fois de plus la question de
leurs intérêts commerciaux
le prince charles aurait demandé aux
comptes de choisir entre sa société de
production et ses fonctions officielles
début 2005 la famille royale est à
nouveau plongé dans l'embarras
suite à la publication de photos
montrant le prince harry
vêtu d'un uniforme nazi à l'occasion
d'une fête costumée et ses images
soulève l'indignation dans le monde
entier
[Musique]
8 en janvier 2005
j'ai publié des photos du prince harry
déguisé en nazi qui allaitent à une fête
avec williams
ces images ont fait scandale
pendant une séance photo officielle de
williams qui faisait du ski en suisse
il m'a rebattu les oreilles avec cette
histoire mais a reconnu que harry avait
eu tort
harry et william ont une relation
spéciale
ils sont très proches et si harry a un
problème
william fait tout son possible pour
l'aider c'est incroyable à quel point
nous sommes devenus proches depuis le
décès de notre mère nous sommes proches
c'est la seule personne sur cette terre
avec qui je veux parler de tout
l'intervention se comprend parfaitement
et on soutient lui a déjà décollé oui
j'ai décollé merci de me demander ça
reste difficile mais je suis meilleur
que williams alors c'est cool mais moi
petit le prince charles n'a rien perdu
de son mépris pour la presse en
particulier britanniques et quelques
semaines seulement après le faux-pas de
harry il comme l une des plus grosses
erreurs de son illustre carrière mars
2005 lors d'un séjour au ski et face à
des journalistes du monde entier
on oublie que son micro est branché et
chacun est alors témoin de son dédain
pour les journalistes et les paparazzi
c'est une charmante pensée n'est ce pas
je suis ravi que vous en ayez entendu
parler
quelle bande de nuls je ne supporte pas
cet homme
tesla et les pistes de kloster vont
devenir une étape clé dans l'histoire
d'amour royal à 100 lors de ce voyage le
prince william est questionné de façon
très indiscrètes sur sa vie amoureuse et
sa réponse plutôt évasive mais les gros
titres dans le monde entier prince
william
il semble y avoir de l'amour dans l'air
peut-on envisager un autre mariage
prochainement non ça m'étonnerait en
avril 2005 william décide d'emmener kate
middleton sa petite amie à l'époque en
vacances au ski en suisse avec son père
et le prince charles
bien entendu le fait que deux années de
suite
cette jolie brune dont personne ne sait
rien partent en vacances avec le clan a
attiré l'attention des médias
on peut parler de folie médiatique
tous les photographes à skis présent
dans les alpes et se sont précipités
pour prendre des photos de créer au
cours de ces vacances j'ai rencontré
william kate et harry en boîte
tard dans la nuit on a longuement
discuté et william voulez savoir
même si ça semblait évident pourquoi
d'un seul coup les médias se
déchaînaient autour de son séjour au ski
dans les alpes et j'ai été obligé de lui
expliquer qu'il était naturel de
s'intéresser à une fille susceptible de
devenir un jour reine d'angleterre je
pense qu'il comprenait mais qu'il
voulait l'entendre de ma bouche mais
alors il s'est mis à rire m'a dit je ne
comprends pas tout ce fois je ne veux
pas me marier avant d'avoir 28 ou 30 ans
bien sûr je n'oublierai jamais ces mots
c'est amusant cinq ou six ans après
l'avoir rencontrée par hasard en boîte
je me rends compte qu'il me donnait en
fait à ce couple
où est la remise des diplômes de william
et kate en 2005 est un épisode joyau
l'événement fait une fois de plus la une
dans le monde entier les conflits avec
la presse semble être de rigueur pour la
famille royale en 2005
mais tu sais tu allais la kate middleton
ce plan via ses avocats du harcèlement
médiatique dont elle est victime
les avocats du prince william et du
prince charles sont intervenus ont fait
l'impossible pour protéger kate pour
éviter qu'elles soient traqués et
devienne une propriété publique
comme pour la mère du prince william
vers la fin de sa vie cette époque les
deux princes ondes en couple depuis
longtemps harry avec la sud-africaine
chelsy davy et william avec kate ils
font la fête dans les boîtes de nuit de
londres et vivent comme tous les autres
jeunes de leur âge malheureusement en
tant qu'héritier de la couronne ils sont
souvent sur la sellette
le prince harry vit très mal cette
intrusion dans sa vie privée et ses
nombreuses fêtes vous éprouviez du
ressentiment vis-à-vis de certains
articles de presse
est-ce que c'est toujours le cas oui ça
me contrarie toujours et pourtant je les
lis je me demande pourquoi je les lis
pour ma tranquillité d'esprit pour
savoir ce qu'ils ont écrit pour savoir
qui les a écrits et voir les photos
notez bien ça il ne s'agit pas vraiment
de savoir gérer tout ça mais de faire
avec
il n'existe pas de méthode
je ne vais pas lire le journal m'asseoir
dans un coin et méditer j'essaie plutôt
de penser à autre chose
je ne veux pas trop insister avec la
presse vous savez bien que l'intérêt que
vous suscitez vient aussi de ce que vous
êtes
mais vous n'êtes pas le seul à être
touché il ya aussi vos proches surtout
votre petite amie
comment réagit style ressentez-vous le
besoin de les protéger
oui vraiment et je m'inquièterais si je
ne les protège pas ça fait partie de ma
vie
quelque chose d'inhérent à ma partition
le comprend et mes amis
le comprennent aussi je crois qu'on peut
dire que c'est inévitable mais par
contre les mensonges ne viennent pas de
moi je ne devrait probablement pas en
parler mais ça arrive je vous comprenez
avec les médias en général il y à des
vérités et des mensonges et
malheureusement je ne peux pas rétablir
la vérité car je n'ai pas ma propre
colonnes dans le journal mais j'y pense
et concernant ma copine c'est ma vie
privée et c'est une autre histoire
mais oui je tente vraiment de la
protéger
kate et william ont commencé leur vie
post universitaires comme la plupart des
jeunes hommes de la famille royale
williams suit un entraînement militaire
avant de rejoindre la royal air force où
il apprend à piloter ce qui deviendra
pour lui une véritable passion
tout est bon sur la piste on est prêt au
décollage
comment ça se passe dans le ciel très
bien j'aime beaucoup ça c'est très
différent de l'armée oui par certains
côtés mais on retrouve le même esprit de
camaraderie et tout le monde s'entend
très bien
je crois savoir que vous avez fait votre
premier vol solo lierre oui c'est vrai
comment c'était je suis désolé de vous
dire ça mais je ne suis pas fait pour
les avions mais pour l'instant ça va
si le genre d'expérience que je ne
pensais jamais vivre
je me disais qu'avec un peu de chance
j'aurai plus d'entraînement je me suis
retrouvé assis à regarder autour de moi
en disant up quoi mais oui ça s'est bien
passé mais kate a bien du mal à trouver
ses marques après saint-andrews situe
elle travaille un temps pour la chaîne
de vêtements britannique dixsaut mais
abandonne rapidement
elle semble avoir d'autres
préoccupations
selon mes sources elle passait le plus
clair de son temps sur le parking a
parlé au téléphone avec williams et
quand ils se disputaient elle revenait
en larmes s'impliquer déjà beaucoup dans
cette relation
et puis il ya eu ce scandale selon
lequel elle allait étudier la
photographie avec mario testino qui
était un ami de la famille et il a tout
démenti
ensuite elle a décidé de travailler pour
ses parents c'était sûrement la décision
la plus sage parce que personne ne
pouvait dire quoi que ce soit sur les
heures qu'elle faisait réellement et
elle pouvait consacré toute sa vie à
être la petite amie de william je pense
que c'est ce genre de chose qui lui a
valu le surnom de waitie katie katie la
patiente
parce qu'elle a vraiment renoncé à sa
vie pour être toujours au côté de
william comme un larbin est cependant le
travail qui consiste à être les plages
où la fiancée de william ressemble
vraiment à ça je pense que kate mon
réa la famille royale qu'elle était
prête et désireuse de faire ce qu'on
attendait d'elle pour remplir ce rôle
williams l'entraînement militaire à la
royal air force commence pour de bon
pour williams 1 2 ghz et lorsqu'il se
termine qu'à était là pour voir son
prince recevoir ses galons et afficher
fièrement son soutien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
opentext chapitres suivants de
l'histoire d'amour royal choc le monde
entier en particulier la presse
britannique en avril 2007 william et
kate
ces parcours d'un autre séjour aux
sports d'hiver a été avec le recul je
pense que la pression des fiançailles
était trop forte pour williams et des
photos d'eux avait été publiée annonçant
qu'il s'était déjà séparé selon des
proches ils n'ont jamais vraiment rompu
vous voulez simplement ne plus être dans
la ligne de mire du public pour prendre
le temps de réfléchir à ce qu'ils
allaient faire mais ils sont toujours
restés en contact pendant cette période
il arrivait d'ailleurs de se retrouver
discrètement au peuple pour passer du
temps ensemble ils n'ont jamais cessé de
se voir mais à mon avis williams s'est
demandé pendant un temps s'il avait le
droit de continuer à farhat hockey comme
s'il allait oui ou non les poupées
russes ou le monde pensait que kate et
william allait se marier
cela faisait longtemps qu'ils étaient
ensemble et quand ils se sont séparés
les gens se sont rendu compte que
finalement il était humain leur rupture
a été très médiatisé des photos du
prince william en train de se promener
avec une fille près de l'endroit où il
faisait son service militaire et on ne
pouvait pas s'empêcher de penser à ce
que ça a dû être terrible pour kate et
elle est restée digne tout le temps je
pense que personne ne s'attendait à ce
qu'ils se remettent ensemble parce qu'il
devait y avoir une raison à leur rupture
alors quand ça s'est produit c'était la
preuve que leur relation était sérieuse
williams a dit qu'il était très inquiet
de toutes ces pressions il voulait être
sûre qu'elle savait vraiment où elle
mettait les pieds
alors il a décidé qu'il devait prendre
le temps de réfléchir
est ce que tu es se faire un break pour
qu'elle puisse vraiment réfléchir à tout
ça et je pense que ce qu'elle a répondu
on est extrêmement révélateur
là elle a dit qu'elle n'était pas
contente du tout il fallait qu'on fasse
notre chemin tout seul et on était en
train de devenir adulte donc on avait
besoin d espace pour réfléchir à ce
qu'on devait faire
je pense qu'à ce moment là je n'étais
pas très contente de la situation mais
ça m'a rendue plus forte
ça permet de découvrir des choses sur
soi dont on n'a pas conscience
ironie du sort la réconciliation arrive
à un moment très délicat pour williams
à l'occasion du concert marquant le
dixième anniversaire de la mort de diana
est discrète comme à son habitude sa
qualité assise derrière william pendant
le concert pop mais les médias
interprètent cela comme la preuve que le
couple est à nouveau réuni
au ball trap aux histoires d'amour du
couple royal se poursuit williams se
fait taper sur les doigts pour avoir
abusé de sa position au sein de la royal
air force
on raconte qu'il organise à grands frais
d'émission inutile pour venir surprendre
qu'un prince william le prince william
adoré piloter il avait appris à voler
pendant sa formation à la royal air
force a montré son côté aventurier il
était tout le temps à bord d'un avion
pour donner les cocktails mais la chose
à laquelle il n'avait pas réfléchi c'est
que la presse britannique allait
surveiller son nombre de vols et lui
dire que c'était de l'argent public et
qu'il n'avait pas à faire ça selon des
rumeurs il aurait même volé jusqu'à la
maison de kate et se serait posé dans
son jardin juste pour lui faire une
surprise si bien sûr très romantique je
pense que la plupart des gens ne
trouverait rien à redire mais les médias
n'ont pas vu ça du même oeil
avec une tenue tu continues à passer des
soirées en ville souvent en compagnie du
prince harry et de sa petite amie par
intérim chelsea il fréquente les
endroits les plus huppés de los angeles
est pas rare de les voir avec ou sans
leurs copines traîner dans les boîtes de
nuit de londres se saouler il ya une des
nuits de folie et des additions vraiment
salée certains les critiquent et en
disant que c'était un signe de dérapage
mais bon deux jeunes d'une vingtaine
d'années qui prennent du bon temps
ça ne fait de mal à personne ne pourra
rien
ce genre de scénario a l'air de se
répéter de temps en temps mais william
comprend forcément qu'il doit désormais
prendre de la distance par rapport à ce
genre de choses
[Musique]
et une boulette et william vont en boîte
il fréquente des endroits où tout le
monde peut aller comme le mic et où le
bout de 10 mais en même temps il
s'entoure souvent de nombreux amis très
protecteur ils forment un clan très
privé et digne de confiance
le 'rafale' date celle ci est l'un des
endroits préférés de kate mais c'est un
club privé très huppé et je pense
qu'elle se sent en sécurité quand elles
passent la soirée là bas il ne déboule
pas dans n'importe quelle boîte de nuit
et bien sûr ils font attention
par exemple le maïs qui appartient en
partie à guy pelly en très bonne amie de
harry et william donc et choisissent
minutieusement le lieu et le moment où
ils sortent
je sais par exemple que pour le prince
harry il téléphone à l'avance pour être
sûr que la sécurité sera suffisante et
il passe par une entrée privée
ces clubs entoure les membres de la
famille royale de beaucoup de soins
parce qu'ils sont vraiment contents
d'être associés à eux
[Musique]
holy louisiane décide de faire sa
demande lors d'un voyage au kenya
il a toujours adoré l'afrique et
entreprend ce voyage pour fêter
l'obtention de son diplôme dans l'unité
recherche et sauvetage de la royal air
force qui a été particulièrement
difficile
arrivé en avion sur les terres que sa
famille connaît depuis des générations
l'avion de ian craig atterri à les oies
la retraite romantique où le prince
william a décidé de demander la main de
kate sensible aux souhaits d'intimité de
william craig l'ami de la famille
accueille le couple lors de son séjour
au kenya
le prince william est bien entendu un
ami intime et nous connaissons quête
depuis plusieurs années il forme un
couple comme tant d'autres dans le monde
ils sont amoureux ils sont extrêmement
chaleureux même s'ils ont accueilli le
couple
il dit que son épouse jane et lui même
ont appris la nouvelle des fiançailles
qui hier j'ai été extrêmement émue
j'étais pour ma part très fier pour le
kenya pour william et kate pour le monde
entier
les implications du magnifique mariage
de deux personnes si spécial c'était une
excellente nouvelle pour nous les
animaux sauvages du kenya ont sans doute
été les seuls témoins du moment
williams a sorti la bad de son sac à dos
pour la glisser au doigt de kate
nous étions avec des amis et je ne m'y
attendais pas du tout je me disais qu'il
y avait peut-être déjà réfléchi mais
j'ai été vraiment prise de court quand
c'est arrivé et je suis vraiment ravi si
kate n'a pas senti venir la question de
william
alors je me demande sur quelle planète
lv honnêtement tout le monde s'y
attendait j'ai découvert récemment par
des gens travaillant au valais qu'il
était convaincu que william profiterait
de ce séjour pour enfin la demander en
mariage il était prêt à l'annoncer à
leur retour
mais le grand père de kate était très
malade il est d'ailleurs mort quelques
semaines plus tard sinon il l'aurait
annoncé bien avant
alors le fait que kate n'ai rien vu
venir
je trouve ça difficile à croire mais je
suis sûr que c'est ce qu'elle est censée
dire nous parlions mariage depuis déjà
un moment est donc pas une énorme
surprise mais je les ai emmenés dans un
endroit sympa au kenya
j'ai fait ma demande c'était très
romantique
il est un grand romantique c'est vrai je
suis sûr que c'était très romantique
c'est sûrement agenouillé mais je sais
que ça s'est passé dans l'intimité
c'est ce qu'il voulait quelque chose de
privé du c'est à ce moment là que vous
avez sorti la bague
cela faisait environ trois semaines
qu'il était dans mon sac à dos et je ne
voulais pas la perdre de vue parce que
je savais que si elle disparaissait
je serai dans un sacré pétrin mais oui
tout s'est bien passé
on entend parfois des histoires
horribles sur les demandes en mariage
tout s'est très bien passé elle a dit
oui c'est moche mais comme dans la
plupart des familles il existe un secret
bien gardé un mouton noir qui plonge
kate dans l'embarras et depuis il s'agit
du frère de sa mère son oncle gary
goldsmith
ils ont leur foi ibiza l'île de
prédilection du fn depuis cinq ans comme
toutes les familles les middleton ont
aussi des choses à cacher la famille
royale à fergie alors c'est normal que
kate et gary goldsmith
cessons donc un grand fêtard qui va
souvent à ibiza il a fait les gros
titres parce qu'ils se droguent et yvan
peut-être de la drogue
il est couvert de tatouages ce n'est
vraiment pas le genre de personne qu'on
imagine apparenté à la famille royale
il s'est fait tatouer nouveaux riches
dans le dos il serait impliqué dans un
trafic de drogue
ce n'est pas le genre de chose qu'on
souhaite associer à la famille royale
mais le prince william est quand même
allé à ibiza avec elle ça semble
inimaginable au premier abord ils ont
séjourné chez sait-on ce live qui sera
apparemment invités au mariage
ce qui promet d'être intéressant à mon
avis les médias vont s'en donner à coeur
joie
cela ramène le couple à un niveau
ordinaire auquel tout le monde peut
s'identifier
le fait d'avoir un peu monté d'un membre
de sa peine
asthme était comme d'habitude tuque ait
réussi à faire bonne figure mais est
elle vraiment aussi sage et persécuté
qu'elle en a l'air selon moi leur
relation est fondée sur les recettes
elle n'a jamais été une cendrillon et où
un paillasson
elle a toujours défendu ses positions
quelqu'un lui a dit tu en as de la
chance de sortir avec le prince william
et elle a répondu non c'est lui qui a de
la chance de sortir avec si vous mêmes
si elles se situent en dessous de lui
sur l'échelle sociale
elle ne s'est jamais considéré comme
inférieur je pense qu'elle agit avec
maturité de façon presque maternelle
elle n'a jamais connu de scandale mais
il n'y a jamais eu de scandale lié à la
drogue ou à des problèmes du même genre
vous pouvez être sûr que les tabloïds
anglais l'origine je pense que notre
pays a énormément de chance d'avoir
quelqu'un comme kate dans la famille
royale parce que c'est une fille
adorable vraiment gentil je pense
qu'elle a tout ce qu'il faut
elle est discrète aimable elle a sacré
sens de l'humour et je sais qu'avec
l'amour qu'ils se portent tous les deux
ils seront capables de traverser tous
les obstacles que la vie mettra sur leur
schéma est quelqu'un de très obstiné
c'est une bonne chose j'ai beaucoup de
vies pourraient s'identifier à elle
les gens ont surnommé le critiquer et
pink eyes la patiente
parce qu'elle a attendu la demande en
mariage du prince pendant huit ans
[Musique]
un mois laisse plus mais qui est
vraiment le prince william quand vous
avez la chance de parler à williams
c'est incroyable de voir comment il se
comporte à quel point il est équilibré
le prince william et jouit d'une
position solide rimbaud yeux de la
presse
je pense que les médias et le public
l'admin a été obligé de grandir très
vite c'est clair surtout après le décès
de sa mère c'est lui le plus mûr par
rapport à son frère le prince harry je
pense que les gens l'apprécient et le
respectent et en même temps se sentent
proches de céder pas un membre de la
famille royale qui prend ses distances
par rapport de 500 musiques qui se
soucie véritablement des gens perplexes
[Musique]
skymark est peut-être devenir une icône
de l'élégance à l'image de diana ça lui
plaise ou non
kaïs sera comparé à diana en tant
qu'icône de la mode je ne pense pas
qu'elle ait le droit à l'expérimentation
qu'avait d anna 6 mai l épouse de
l'héritier de la couronne bas vise y
aura donc très nombreux créateurs qui
feront elles portent leurs vêtements
elle va donc apprendre à cultiver son
propre style et à aimer la mode
peut-être plus que maintenant parce que
tout va lui tomber du ciel n'a pas le
charisme le magnétisme de diana elle n'a
pas le même amour pour la caméra que
diana cependant la beauté de kate son
élégance et son sens inné de ce qui la
met en valeur vont lui permettre d'aller
très loin
elle figure déjà en tête de plusieurs
listes pour ses tenues et je pense que
ça continuera à mesure qu'elle trouvera
ses marques
moi je parie que dire de la décision
controversée de william de donner à sa
fiancée la bague de la princesse diana
moment aussi plus superstitieux voudrait
entendre que cette dalle porte malheur
mais william n'éprouve pas ce genre de
réticences c'est une blague de famille
qui appartenait m je me suis dit que
c'était une bonne chose parce qu'elle
n'est plus là pour partager ces moments
heureux avec nous c'était une façon pour
moi de la garder président je crois que
beaucoup de gens étaient étonnés que
william downe à kate la bague de
fiançailles de sa mère parce que son
mariage a été tellement malheureux et
qu'elle a trouvé la mort de façon
tragique
il aurait été compréhensible qu'elles
reçoivent cette balle mais pas comme une
bague de fiançailles qu'elles portent
tous les jours malgré la malchance dont
parle certaines personnes cela prouve
que la mère de william a une place
importante dans son coeur cela montre à
quel point il aime il voulait faire
participer sa mère à ce jour très
spécial
la bad va parfaitement à kate elle n'a
pas été modifié on dirait qu'elle a été
fait pour elle il a dit qu'il voulait
associer sa mère à l'événement cela
n'avait rien de ma cave
ce n'est pas comme un spectre du passé
qu'il a fait ça pour que le souvenir de
sa mère soit associée aux célébrations
et au bonheur qui entoure ce grand
évènement pense que le jour où il a
offert la bague
c'était un moyen pour lui de prendre les
rênes de cette histoire de la maîtriser
c'est à mon avis ce qu'il voulait il
nous a tous conviés à inclure sa mère
dans ce mariage et c'est ce que tout le
monde fera le prince william ne parle
que très rarement de sa mère en public
vous filez vite de faire quoi que ce
soit pour établir des comparaisons avec
sa mère il déteste certainement l'idée
que kate puisse être perçue comme la
nouvelle diana
nous voulons façonné notre propre avenir
et personne n'essaie de prendre la place
de ma mère ce qu'elle faisait était
fantastique
il s'agit de forger son propre destin et
je suis sûr que kate se quittera très
bien de cette tâche
causse
s'il avait décidé d'aller à la
bijouterie pour acheter une bague de
fiançailles les gens l'auraient accusé
d'exclure diana de l'histoire le prince
william ne ferai jamais une chose
pareille
sa mère reste le personnage central de
sa vie les réactions à l'annoncé des
fiançailles royal ont été diverses
simple certaines étaient prévisibles
d'autres moins c'est une excellente
nouvelle je suis vraiment contente pour
eux ils sont tellement heureux c'est
fantastique quel est votre réaction à
l'annoncé du mariage
je suis bien sûr ravi merci beaucoup ça
fait longtemps que je m'entraîne comme
vous le savez
catherine et le prince william se
fréquentent depuis de longues années ce
qui est une bonne chose car cela nous a
permis de bien connaître williams
trouvons merveilleux et nous avons
beaucoup d'affection pour lui il forme
un être beau couple dano pa sont de très
bons moments ensemble
nous rions beaucoup nous leur souhaitons
tout le bonheur du monde
j'assistais à une réunion du conseil des
ministres
quand j'ai appris la nouvelle on m'a
donné un papier pour annoncer la
nouvelle
tout le monde s'est mis à applaudir et à
taper sur la table
wanted est diablement l'arrivée de kate
middleton dans la famille royale va
changer les choses et comment s'adaptera
tel aux limites imposées par l'une des
plus anciennes dynasties au monde fera
les choses à sa manière elle saura
s'imposer à sa façon b et je crois
qu'elle sera une reine consort de l'ère
moderne
nous verrons une famille royale moins
imposante peut-être un peu moins austère
et rigide
je pense qu'ils seront de bons
dirigeants dans ce contexte et qu'ils
apporteront un souffle d'air frais dans
l'atmosphère figée de buckingham palace
je crois qu'ils feront de l'excellent
travail
la monarchie britannique va forcément
changer en fonction de ceux qui seront
aux commandes
et ce jeune couple moderne fera les
choses différemment un des secrets les
mieux gardés dans tout mariage royal et
l'identité du créateur de la robe pour
le mariage de la princesse diana et du
prince charles en 1981 la robe bouffante
créée par elizabeth emmanuel est restée
secrète jusqu'au grand jour
la robe que diana portait ce n'était pas
et ce n'était pas une belle robe
des années après on a su qu'elle même ne
l'aimé pas
je l'aimé bien s'intéressaient tout ça
la robe
tout le monde voulait savoir à quoi elle
allait ressembler cosmébio sûr on ne
pouvait rien dire
toutes les nuits il faisait les
poubelles pour essayer de trouver des
morceaux de tissus ou de films et ont
jeté des morceaux de toutes les couleurs
pour les induire en erreur
nous avons dû installer des stores pour
que les gens ne regardent pas par les
fenêtres on a fait venir des gardiens
c'était peut-être un peu trop on aurait
sans doute pu se passer de l'énorme
coffre fort dans lequel on mettait la
robe toutes les nuits mais on ne voulait
prendre aucun risque y est on avait même
une deuxième robe au cas où quelqu'un
aurait réussi à percer le secret le
créateur choisi pour faire la robe aura
beaucoup de chance car elle a une
silhouette magnifique hameçon elle est
mince comme un fil tournage est très
séduisante elle sait se mouvoir
sa démarche est sublime sans être
ostentatoire
tous les créateurs prestigieux vont se
battre pour habiller kate middleton elle
choisira certainement un créateur
britannique ce qui serait logique
bruce oldfield un couturier britannique
qui avait déjà les faveurs de diana est
vraiment le favori c'est sûrement lui
qui confectionnera la robe la mère et la
soeur de kate ont été récemment aperçue
dans la boutique ultra chic de brousse
il est descendu leur parler en personne
ce qu'il ne fait jamais d'habitude
cela confirme les soupçons ce sera
sûrement lui qui habillera à kate et sa
soeur pour le grand jour je connais très
bien beau je ne pense pas que ce sera
lui qui fera la robe de mariée
simplement parce qu'ils en parlent
si c'était lui il n'en parlerai pas je
crois cependant que vossen reeves sera
la tenue de madame middleton kate
middleton a assez de courage et toute
personnalité pour choisir le créateur
qu'elle
shimon sociale et sa guise à la
créatrice parce qu'elle a souvent porter
des robes dix ans la robe bleue qu'elle
portait pour les fiançailles était une
création issa mais qui sait ce sera
peut-être un britannique
donc on verra de toute façon ce sera
magnifique
elle ne peut pas se tromper on me poser
la question mais au bout du compte que
cet accueil de jendouba et et je ne sais
même pas si ce sera un couturier
britannique as-tu vraiment je n'en sais
rien
ce sera un secret jalousement gardé des
stars parce qu'elle ne voudra pas que
quiconque le sache jusqu'au grand jour
on a même parlé de victoria beckham ce
qui serait plutôt inhabituel je serais
étonné qu'elle l'a choisi mais ça me
plairait je lis partout que la robe
brodée manche
apparemment et je pense que ce sera le
cas parce que c'est un mariage royal
solennelle qu'elle n'est pas du genre à
juste vouloir être belle dans une robe
sans bretelles ce soir à tendance est
convenable on peut le dire comme ça
peut-être stella mccartney elle vient
d'une famille anoblie de musiciens siglé
son père paul mccartney connaît très
bien la famille royale c'est une
possibilité
je pense qu'elle choisira une robe
qu'audrey hepburn habillée par givenchy
aurait pu porter au sommet de sa gloire
ce sera ça élégant et très séduisant
tant pour les hommes que pour les femmes
que demander de plus à une épouse royale
rien n'a été très jeune quand elle est
arrivée sur le devant de la scène
elle ne s'intéressait pas beaucoup à la
mode elle n'avait pas encore son propre
style
mais kate middleton est différente elle
a travaillé dans la mode et c'est se
mettre en valeur
elle a certainement une idée très
précise du genre de robe qu'elle veut la
chine china
[Musique]
à moins que c'est que pense la presse
britannique toujours très critique des
perspectives d'avenir du jeune couple
royal je pense que les choses peuvent
marcher entre william et kate
ils sont tous les deux très attachés à
la monarchie et affrontent ensemble tous
les problèmes personnels qu'ils peuvent
rencontrer kate a montré qu'elle avait
l'esprit d'équipé est là a montré
qu'elle était capable de faire passer
ses propres intérêts après ceux de son
futur mari ils sont ensemble depuis huit
ans ils ont vécu un tas de choses
ensemble et will i am semble être
capable de la préparer bien mieux au
rôle de membre de la famille royale que
charles ne l'a fait pour sa mère ce
qu'elle peut donc se reposer sur
williams elle peut se reposer sur sa
famille
ce qui n'était pas le cas pour diana
elle est avec un homme qu'elle connaît
depuis huit ans je pense qu'ils ont
toutes leurs chances
leur relation a grandi dans les nuits
froides hiver dans des studios
universitaire à manger des spaghettis
bolognaise et a parlé de tout sauf du
rôle de princes et de princesses de roi
ou reine d'angleterre
leur relation s'est développée alors
qu'ils étaient simplement william et
kate et je pense que c'est une chose qui
vont essayer de conserver tout au long
de leur vie conjugale l'elysée
parviennent alors il y a de grandes
chances qu'ils restent ensemble très
longtemps je sais qu'il souhaite de tout
son coeur avoir une vie de famille et je
suis sûr que si tout se passe bien
son voeu se réalise deviendront aussi
populaire au 21ème siècle que la reine
mère l'a été au pâtis à risque
je pense que les gens verront en eux un
couple royal des temps modernes
et avoir une vie paisible ce qui est
parfait pour quelqu'un qui va diriger le
pays
il ne va pas s'attirer d'ennuis laissera
sa à son frère harry alors que williams
continue son service au sein de la royal
air force à anglesey au nord du pays de
galles la vie quotidienne du couple
royal est réputé très calme
contrairement aux précédentes
générations royal pains c'est le lieu de
résidence exact de william et kate
après leur mariage mais tenu secret
williams est actuellement pilote au sein
de l'unité recherche et sauvetage de la
royal air force sur une petite île au
nord du pays de galles
il loue une propriété là bas mais on ne
sait pas grand chose sur cet endroit
mais il va y vivre sans domestique
ce qui veut dire que quand il rentrera
du travail qui lui fera sans doute à
dîner je n'ai absolument rien contre
andreev
mais ce n'est pas vraiment le genre
d'endroit où on imagine un jeune prince
et son épouse il n'y a pas grand chose à
y faire excepté promener son chien
et c'est à peu près tout donc ils
veulent vivre à wangen bei
les deux premières années de leur
mariage tout en gardant une adresse à
londres comme résidence officielle
il souhaite avoir une vie normale
des 6-9 belle histoire d'amour royal a
captivé des millions de personnes le
prince william semble aujourd'hui avoir
trouvé le bonheur aux côtés de kate
middleton
un autre jeune femme ordinaire issu
d'une famille pauvre deux mineurs dont
le destin exceptionnel l'amènera à
devenir un jour reine d'angleterre d'un
coach il annonce du mariage royal s'est
fait attendre mais leur amour peut
désormais briller au grand jour sous les
regards bienveillants de tous le prince
william et kate middleton peuvent
aborder en toute confiance en un avenir
fait d'espoir et de projets le monde
entier soit au jeune couple royal toute
la chance et tout l'amour du monde
[Musique]